übrigens ab hiess collecting von rolex
[Musik]
einen guten zweck also ja es sieht zwar
aus wie der verlorenen bruder von patch
vor henning heute geht es aber nicht um
aktien
wir werden heute versuchen den
amerikanischen traum eines jeden kindes
war zu machen indem wir geld mit einem
lemonade an fakten wie viel das sein
wird was wir verkaufen und was wir alles
machen das hier jetzt viel spaß mit dem
video in den filmen wird das immer
glorifiziert die kinder stellen sich auf
die straße verkaufen limonade in
abgewandelter form können wir das in
deutschland auch machen wir können keine
offenen getränke verkaufen wir können
nicht das verkaufen würden das nicht
verkaufen aber wir können geschlossener
getränke verkaufen können gerade sondern
kaufen könnt ihr verkaufen
wir können cola fanta sprite die
standard sachen können wir verkaufen
als allererstes müssen wir dafür unsere
getränke einkaufen kleine marktanalyse
wir können natürlich jetzt nicht an
einem tag so viel erfahrung sammeln dass
wir wissen was verkauft sich am besten
was verkauft sich gar nicht und deswegen
fragen wir bei den leuten nach die ihr
geld damit jetzt schon hatten was ist
eigentlich das getränk was sich am
besten verkauft wer hätte es gedacht die
gute alte maate kann man auch relativ
teuer verkaufen also wenn man jetzt in
so einem kleinen stand ist was nimmt man
dafür also safe 2 aber vielleicht sogar
250 also club mate fritz kola
capri-sonne durstlöscher sind die einen
alkoholischen getränke die am besten
laufen also kaufen wir genau die
wir sind durch was wir bezahlt haben wie
viel umsatz wie man das schon jetzt
leicht mal wenn wir alles von außen
kommen
insgesamt 90 euro und 7 cent ausgegeben
mehrwertsteuer so es gab schon einige
kommentare dazu mehrwertsteuer nicht
ganz zusammen gibt es in diesem projekt
nicht wenn wir alles verkauft bekommen
machen wir einen umsatz von das war
richtig geil aber weniger als gedacht
wir haben zwei kästen club mate ein
kasten fritz kohler ein paket wasser und
dreimal kap die somit mehr gibt es dann
an unserem level stent nicht und damit
müssen sich dann die leute zufrieden
geben
hier sicherte monate verkaufen häufiger
in der limonade verkauft und dann glaube
ich nicht mal das angebot
wir stellen einmal demonstrativ alles
aus was wir haben mit so eis so dass sie
das bekommen könnt ihr mit eurem geld
überreicht werden wir vielleicht gibt's
ja auch noch leute die das ganze projekt
noch ein bisschen mehr
vielleicht sollten wir so einen
spendentopf aufstellen wänden für rolex
ja genauso machen müssen lemonade stand
sie ja nicht los natürlich kommt auch
die echte dpa lhe nach ich drauf das ist
kein geld direkt in meine rolle die es
vielleicht doch nicht meine rolex oder
zu mir in den nächsten videos bitte
geben sie mir geld ich brauche eine
rolex-uhr max und da habe ich doch her
ich danke geworden
da kann ich ehrlich das ist ja mal
besser
das ist ja schon 0 0 0 1 2 prozent der
rolex frau ich bin ehrlich gespannt ob
und wie viel geld oder mit 40 auf ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass es gar nicht
funktion
oder ist leute das bild ich bin ja ja
genau oder dann einfach mehr geld in die
trinkgeld rolex kasse kommt als
investoren
[Musik]
wir sind angekommen
hoffentlich ort des glücks sind am
aachener weiher einer der bestbesuchten
parks in köln und wir werden uns direkt
an den eingang stellen also jeder der
rhein will jeder der raus will muss an
unserem stand vorbei gehen wir jetzt
direkt hier vorne aufschlagen werden und
dann hoffentlich hoffentlich entweder
ein paar spenden bekommen oder die
gesamten getrennt es fühlt sich ziemlich
bald ein bisschen unangenehm wie sommer
ist zu ende und ich mache das jetzt
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen in meinem ganz
eigenen erster lemonade cent
es ist soweit der lemonade steht wir
sitzen seit einer minute und jetzt kann
es losgehen ich hoffe dass hier ein paar
leute vorbeikommen die durstig sind die
unsere getränke abnehmen und dann hoffe
ich auf großen umsatz und noch viel
größere spenden mein bedürfnis steht auf
dem spenden ding und ich hoffe die leute
nehmen das wahr und nehmen das ernst
[Musik]
der hammer
gut aufgestellt ihr habt schon dass ein
genauer ja unser schild vorne haft
eisgekühlte getränke
wenn man dann tatsächlich nur eis
gekühlten da er dann nehme ich nicht
okay aber ich würde euch damit haben wir
für euch allen eine steuer dann gewerbe
maßnahmen multi bad
multicar money also ist gut dass sie da
sind damit war ein bisschen zeit zum
durchatmen habe ich sehe daher dr platz
ist weiß halt deine fresse ich glaub da
hinten ist das denken ist alle leute die
ohne getränke zum aachener weiher kommen
was ihr sehr viele machen die müssen
alle hier haben mir vorbei ist es
schlauer seine produkte selbst zu
konsumieren
ich glaube ich muss erst ein bisschen
was verschenken was machst du gerne
haben
neben dem klub neuer du kannst nach
eigenem bemessen etwas in die rolex
passt tun
du kannst ja auch wieder etwas
rausnehmen
danke ja genauso gut einen cent geben um
fünf monate davon nehmen oder in dem
eine marke für zwei euro
dein körper gut gelaunt
vielen dank jungs ja besser kann es
nicht laufen also die leute anzusprechen
funktioniert tatsächlich lässt ganz kurz
für mich das verkaufen übernehmen ich
muss kurz telefonieren
marien hat es gibt die nicht nur karten
die doch es gibt auch pate für mich sein
wo ich bin und gesagt was machen sie
heute noch was los wenn die kölner zeit
stehen geblieben
hier war es einfach so mitnehmen
doch zwei euro ja die schönsten mädchen
die wir uns nehmen
der kleinbus bestätigen durchkommen
die menschen werden reich ist nicht da
wie gesagt ein nagel
aber jetzt haben
[Applaus]
sollte ein wasser fließen
wenn ihr jetzt keine lust habt könnt ihr
auch nur wenn es galt sich wieder den
greenfreeze collecting von rolex
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich warte noch einmal doch wofür macht
für den euro ländern für den guten zweck
was ist ein guter zweck das ist ja eine
rolex-uhr für mich eine kleine spende
ich kann eine gold creole spenden unsere
echt gold die könnt ihr einfach einen
bösen den fernsehmarkt heute paar
verloren darf ich darauf weist noch doch
tatsächlich ich danke dir mal aber ist
winterthur leiter immer seine caprice
gibt es gleich sondern wirtschaft ist
sich 60 80 85 90 7 80 eur 76 verdient ja
quasi kein - und das video war ein
voller erfolg wenn ich das video
gefallen hat lassen wir gerne leider
vergessen kann als abonnieren und wir
haben außerdem noch eine goldkette
geschenkt bekommen dass kein witz und
die ist wirklich cool wir sehen uns
nächste woche ist macht's gut
[Musik]